you all watch last night did you watch
you know what I'm talking about yes it
was a great episode of 60 minutes that's
what Lesley Stahl was on fire yeah I had
a 60 minutes viewing party last night no
I'm not talking about 60 minutes Game of
Thrones that it's bad I think I think
it's the first new episode since 1988 a
long time anyway yeah it's a big deal
and you know I'm a fanatic I know you
love the show a lot of us love that show
I was waiting I was so desperate for the
new show and apparently a lot of people
were because the statistics are in the
premiere of Game of Thrones last night
this final season drew 17 million
viewers 7 to 17 million viewers
unfortunately for HBO they were all
using the same password they made 11
dollars last night everyone in the
country wait what was it again told you
you know with Game of Thrones thing
about this with Game of Thrones ending
soon because it ends in just what's
gonna be just six episodes and then it's
done that's it so with Game of Thrones
ending soon HBO is scrambling to find
ways to keep their subscribers happy
they're trying to come up with something
I cracked it HBO I've got three words
for you Sopranos on dragons
I'm making them more of a cowboy yeah
yeah it's hard to do a mafia guy now
mops you guys don't really going and the
rest of the do is like a cowboy with a
shopping cart yeah yeah look I didn't
quite have it now I'm gonna work I'm
gonna work on that impression for you
and and then never show it to you again
a lot of violence on that show there is
violence murder murder they've got you
know what there's even incest on that
show yes
no don't woo
[Music]
we we know that we can do a show now we
we know someone's search terms yeah it's
just not something you see on television
a lot now and there's there's more than
one incidence of incest on Game of
Thrones I'm telling you folks I haven't
seen that much incest since I got my
results from 23andme
so wait a minute I'm okay with you not
laughing and in fact in that situation
that would have been the correct
response but what you did was so much
worse yeah you listened and then you
went
and then you were
[Music]
look at him he's wearing a jean jacket
anyway I mean he's got so many genetic
problems that was pathetic
um you know like that well we're here